[Applaudissements]
on est de retour à enquête et anne à la
fin du mois d'août dernier michel
fournier qui est l'ancien grand patron
de la société des ponts reconnu avoir
touché un pot-de-vin de plus de 2
millions de dollars de la part de snc
lavalin parce qu'il leur avait accordé
le contrat de réfection du pont jacques
cartier en 2000 il a fini par plaider
coupable à deux chefs d'accusation
fraude envers le gouvernement et
recyclage des produits de la criminalité
ce qui veut dire de mon blanchiment
d'argent
il ya plus chemin de la prison
immédiatement et anne c'est vous qui
aviez révélé cette histoire là à enquête
en 2014
on va en écouter un extrait
1er novembre 2001 couple dans la
cinquantaine de saint-jean-sur-richelieu
en montérégie ont rendez vous en suisse
plus précisément à zurich
le couple est là pour ouvrir un compte
elle rencontre un banquier d'une société
assez particulière la banque privée
tempus réservé aux plus fortunés du
monde
[Musique]
le compte sera conjoint ce sera un conte
un numéro et aucune trace de leur
identité ne devra apparaître sur les
relevés
ils donnent leur adresse sur la rue
coulon à saint jean sur richelieu le
couple montre ces passeports canadiens
comme preuve d'identité
les deux signes ils font un autre choix
celui du nom de code pour leur compte
ils choisissent zorro lecomte euros
appartient à l'ancien pdg de la société
des ponts fédéraux
michel fournier et à sa femme michelle
fournier et de libéral notoire chef de
cabinet de jean chrétien lorsqu'il est
dans l'opposition
directeur général de l'ailé québécoise
du parti libéral
jusqu'à sa nomination à la société des
ponts nous l'avons retrouvé ici loin des
ponts et d'effroi montréalais au bout de
la route
sur cette colline en banlieue de
victoria en colombie britannique
je suis tombé sur les bons formation
assez importante que vient ma doudou
expliquer ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pour faire votre gestion de la société
du cours concernant un composé déjà
ouverts en suisse
maintenant qu'on était cachée selon elle
dans votre camp donc oui vous aviez un
coup vers un compte en banque tempus
contre 0 que vous avez reçu plusieurs
paiements de la société snc lavalin dans
ce conclave jambes en aucune façon malin
surprenant alors de voir le nom de
michel fournier apparaître dans ce
dossier et recevoir des millions de
dollars en versements suspects n'ont
jamais ouvert de compte et autres votre
votre passeport a été donné en garantie
on a vu des photos se fournit j'ai vu
les photos de votre passeport attaché à
ce complot qui s'appelle lors opposer
map les aurons à la banque pompiers
écoutez madame japon j'ai pas eu de
compte que j'ai ouvert à des potes
pourtant les documents bancaires et
juridiques donne des détails troublants
de janvier à octobre 2002 promo tag une
agence régulièrement engagé par
snc-lavalin dépose des sommes
importantes dans le conte euros 230
mille dollars 228 1114 mais cette fois
pour un total de plus de 2 millions de
dollars que se passe-t-il à ce moment là
qui pourrait justifier ces paiements de
2000 à 2002 la société des ponts a
entrepris un grand chantier au pont
jacques cartier
rappelez vous il s'agissait de refaire
tout le tablier du pont de nuit pour ne
pas perturber le trafic
un contrat de 127 millions de dollars
effectué par un consortium dirigé par
snc lavalin
selon michel fournier l'appel d'offres a
été fait dans les règles de l'art ce
post se passe ailleurs mais je peux vous
dire que chez nous aussi été fait de
façon très très très très près le 12
octobre 2000
le contrat est donné à snc lavalin deux
semaines plus tard le 1er novembre
le couple fourni ouvre son compte en
suisse fin 2002 les travaux au pont
jacques cartier se termine
le couple ferme ce compte et transfert 2
millions de dollars dans une autre
banque pasche leurs comptes s'appelle
alors saint jean laville qui l'habitent
alors j'ai jamais reçu porsche ou de
l'apport de la personne sur la vallée de
promo taxez nous quelque chose l'agencé
commerciale utilisée par snc lavalin
pour tout sur le dos il s'appelle
promoteurs n'ont jamais reçu le rouge à
la justice suisse ce printemps ont posé
des questions aux gens des synthés la
vallée sur 1 4 million $ qui a été
versée à votre compte
écoutez j'ai jamais reçu de son nom snc
lavalin
et je le cite tonnes je n'ai jamais reçu
de sommes de snc lavalin 6 comme celle
fournie vous avez dit il m'avait dit ça
et le tenue cette ligne là pendant trois
ans avant d'abdiquer de finalement
plaider coupable il le juge l'a
condamnée à soixante six mois de prison
et soixante six mois ces cinq ans et
demi ce qui est une peine très sévère
pour quelqu'un qui n'a pas d'antécédent
judiciaire
oui vous avez raison le juge dit un
facteur aggravant c'est que pour
collaborer avec la justice michel fourni
c'est un peu mystérieux pour moi jusqu'à
ce que je trouve ces documents sont des
documents de cour dont les scellés ont
été levés 300 pages de fax de courriels
que michel fournier a échangé avec ses
avocats et qui démontre que jusqu'à la
toute fin
il ya tout fait pour entraver les
enquêtes dans ces échanges souvent
écrits à la main on voit que michel
fournier panique la journée la diffusion
du reportage
il appelle à l'aide ses amis du parti
libéral d'abord martin cauchon
ex-ministre retourné à la pratique du
droit qu'il met en contact avec patrice
troyenne relationniste et membre actif
de la commission politique du parti
libéral est aussi avec l'avocat sylvain
lussier
selon ne les faits rapportés par le
reportage sont trop gros pour être vrai
le mot d'ordre est d'aider leurs amis
michel fournier le raconte d'ailleurs
que tout est faux il n'a jamais accepté
de boudevin l'argent dans le compte
suisse appartient à sa belle soeur qu'il
cache à son conjoint c'est ce qu'il
m'avait aussi raconté il ya près de
trois ans en preuve
il déposa justice canada une lettre où
sa belle soeur depuis décédée aurait
demandé au couple d'ouvrir un compte à
zurich et de l'appeler zorro documents
signés sans témoin ni notarié c'est un
abus de confiance
c'est horrible nous avons retrouvé le
marida belle soeur en question à
vancouver il vit à vous montrer cette
lettre la formulation de la lettre n'est
en aucune façon celle de gueule c'est un
jargon juridique qu'elle n'aurait jamais
utilisé clairement l'argent dans le
compte euro ne provenaient pas de la
lettre n'arrête pas l'anc est au
contraire les choses se corsent
le ministère des transports enquête lui
aussi sur l'attribution du contrat à snc
lavalin michel fournier refusent d'y
collaborer
il engage plutôt un avocat criminaliste
stephan angers qui lui est proposée par
son ami martin cauchon son avocat écrit
aux enquêteurs nous avons eu le mandat
de vous informer que monsieur fournier
n'a pas l'intention de répondre
favorablement à votre demande
d'assistance
michel fournier désir que tout cela
cesse dans une note écrite à la main il
rappelle à son avocat on a choisi pour
arrêter tout ça tu m'avais dit que tu
serais là pour arrêter cette folie avant
que ça aille trop loin mais la grc
poursuit son enquête
elle demande à la suisse de lui remettre
les documents bancaires de couple michel
fournier engage alors un avocat en
suisse pour contester l'envoi des
documents au canada la suisse va livrer
les fameux comptes bancaires qui
démontre que les sommes proviennent de
snc lavalin via l' agence promo tag à la
fin michel fournier se plaint d'avoir
dépensé plus de 80 mille dollars pour sa
défense
en vain c'est l'argent de la retraite
qui s'en va écrit-il
fait ou dernier michel fournier se
présente au palais de justice de
montréal avec sa valise il s'apprête à
plaider coupable il sait qu'il ne
sortira pas libre mais va plutôt prendre
le chemin de la prison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est de retour à enquête est toujours
en compagnie de notre collègue de
panassac and celle fournie a plaidé
coupable mais sa femme elle était aussi
accusé est accusé de complicité de
logements d'argent s'était retirée elle
garde la maison le voulez savoir ce qui
s'est passé que l'argent du bout de 20
usines d'aulnay et bien ils risquent
sept cent soixante quinze mille dollars
quand semble-t-il le couple fait de très
mauvais placement
ça a été saisie par le gouvernement mais
lorsque tout le monde veut savoir un
lent depuis ni celui qui a reçu un
pot-de-vin mais qu'est ce qui arrive à
celui qui a donné le pot-de-vin snc
lavalin question 12.3 millions
le procureur veut pas répondre à la
question snc non plus on me renvoie
toujours à la grc et la grc veux pas me
dire si poursuivre ou non l'enquète
quant à moi la grc à toutes les
informations nécessaires pour procéder
si vraiment un but le faire mais il faut
dire qu'elle sensi lavalin au collaborer
à l'enquêté
la firme a ouvert ses livres donc on
s'est vraiment d'où vient l'argent alors
peut-être que ça s'appelle un compromis
aux crânes vous suivez vos dossiers
jusqu'au bout merci beaucoup et c'est
tout pour ce soir on vous remercie de la
part de toute l'équipe d'avoir été là et
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
une autre enquête
[Musique]